البحث يعتقد على ان هذه الميليشيات بدات
فقط في ما بعد 2000
هذا الكلام غير صحيح
الخلايا الايرانيه بدات تتشكل في اليمن
في عام 83 بالتجامل مع تكوين حزب الله في
لبنان
وكان على راس هذه المجموعه
بدر الدين الحوثي ابو عبد الملك
صلاح
المتحدث الرسمي
كانوا هم المسؤولين عن هذه الخلايا
وقاموا بعمليات ارهابيه في صنعاء
قنابل على سينما بلقيس وقتل الحارس
السينما
واعمل اخرى غير هذه
ضبطهم وسجنهم وبعضهم هربوا الى ايران
ثم عاد ببساطه حينها مع الحكومه في عام 86
[موسيقى]
نحن نعتقد ان الدول اللي لها تاثير قوي
ويمكن ان ان تشك ان يشكل موقفها فعلا
الضغط على الميليشيات الحسين ربما على
حسابات
حساباتها المتعلقه بمصالح الاشتراكيه في
المنطقه مرتبطه بالملفات الصناعه في
المنطقه
بالملف الايراني النووي مرتبطه
العلاقه مع ايران قد هي كثيره قضايا كثيره
متشابكه
[موسيقى]